Showing you that is already a giant.
This country is the largest trading
power in the world,
the wells with hundreds of products and
have one of the largest foreign currency
reserves in the entire planet.
I don't see even the petro monarchies in
the Persian Gulf can compete with this
giant country.
Ends with all of this.
It isn't surprising defined.
Some analysts see states that China will
surpass.
The United States is the leading
economic power and they're going to do
that.
We have a lot more inhabitants.
However,
we usually forget a very important thing
and this is the GDP.
Well,
it's not everything.
Economic power.
The real power is closely related to
corporate power and when it comes to
that,
China is still a long way from reaching
the levels of the United States.
If we look at the top 100 largest
companies in the world,
56 of them are Americans and only 11 are
Chinese,
and this is something to really bear in
mind because multinationals in
controlled of foreign investments ends
of 80 percent of the world's exports.
Now the big question is,
what's going to happen to these Chinese
companies in the future?
How are things changing and what can we
really expect?
These are some of the questions that
we're going to be answering in today's
video.
Chinese giant development,
the Chinese economy,
as had unimpressive growth rates in the
last three decades and key to this was
the concept of them being the welds
factory.
This is what China is known for.
They are known as a country that has
become a world power and has lifted
hundreds of thousands of people from
poverty with a relatively simple
premise,
producing everything and producing it at
a low cost.
Toys,
electronics,
tools,
clothing.
When you enter a store,
you aren't going to find hundreds of
products with something in common and
that's that.
They are all manufactured in massive
industrial areas located all over China.
The in order for a country to really be
the leading economic power,
these companies need to start producing
much more complex products.
Mans they will have to stop competing on
cost and start looking at far higher
added value.
This can include the production of
things like capital assets,
planes,
medical devices,
and computer processes.
That driverless car,
I have seen it all entails driving the
future traffic,
light street lamps,
business runs on the cloud,
and the cloud runs on Intel and today
all these sectors are dominated by the
large multinational companies of the
United States,
South Korea,
Europe,
and Japan.
It is true that many leading products
are manufactured in China,
for example,
the iphone,
but this is not exactly true because
what China actually is more like the
assembly.
What this means is that the more complex
parts they're bought from other
countries and then they simply put
together in China to better illustrate
this,
consider this.
Each year trying to import more than
$200,000,000,000
in semiconductors,
which are essential in the manufacturing
of mobile devices.
Just for comparison.
That is more money than what the entire
country spends on petrol.
However,
Chinese companies have made many
advances
today.
A fourth of all exports are capital
goods such as machines for example,
or high tech products.
In some sectors like telecommunications,
wind turbines or high speed trains.
Chinese companies,
all the world leaders,
just that because Chinese companies are
also learning how to make it in the
international market.
Yes,
great.
Chinese conquest.
Two Thousand and 16 was the 40th
anniversary of the ends of the cultural
revolution.
This was a telephone campaign which now
organized in order to purify the
revolution and finish off all remnants
of capitalism in Chinese society.
Since then,
things have changed a lot so much that
China is only behind the United States
in terms of numbers of multinational
companies,
companies in this country that's
starting to make it into global markets
as well.
They're doing it really,
really well.
20 16 Chinese companies spent an
incredible amount of money,
$225,
billion dollars in the purchase of
foreign companies in Europe and the
United States alone.
They acquired more than 450 company.
Chinese companies are buying all kinds
of businesses,
mining companies,
banks,
oil companies,
pharmaceutical companies,
agricultural companies,
even luxury hotel chains,
jewelry companies,
and football clubs.
Yep.
Yeah.
That right to view of the Chinese have
even bought into Milan and that is just
one example.
Just your city gets a $400,
million dollar Chinese investment deal,
but if there is one thing in particular
that the Chinese love to invest in,
well that would be developing country
Australia and the United States are the
two countries that receive the most in
Chinese investment dollars.
More than half of all Chinese investment
is made in emerging countries located in
Asia,
Africa,
Latin America,
and the Middle East.
Almost save at the more risky the
country,
the more willing the Chinese art to
invest in it.
Know this might surprise you,
but this,
this is not the end of the story.
Chinese companies are also starting to
compete hard.
Well,
if there was only one Chinese company
and the top 100 most valuable companies
in 2006,
that was 14 by the year,
2015.
And take a look at the smart phone
industry.
Yeah,
up
until having a Chinese
phone.
Well,
it was a bit weird,
right?
Well today the four main Chinese
manufacturer is Apo.
Huawei,
Vivo in Chalmette ons,
just more famous than they were a few
years ago because they also take more
than 10 percent of the welds profits in
this industry and this is a figure that
is growing more and more every single
year and if you want another example,
whether you just have to look to Lenovo,
which is a Chinese multinational company
that was born just a few years ago and
indeed it bought the laptop division of
IBM and is now the largest computer
company in the world as they even supply
equipment to the Pentagon and how about
even more examples this hire the biggest
manufacturer of household appliances or
go a company that's acquiring land all
over the world like sugarcane
plantations in Australia,
French vineyards or soy plantations in
Brazil and then this Guidea Cola company
which you might not have heard of,
but it actually bought out Volvo in 2010
Volvo.
That legendary Swedish car company is
now property of a Chinese company.
That is a sector where China is really
getting ahead.
It is against all the odds,
the Internet,
and I say against all odds here because
as you probably know,
China is subject to complete control of
its Internet by the Chinese government
with something known as the great
firewall.
This blocks access to you facebook,
Google ends the economist to name just
three.
However,
on the other hand,
in China,
it's pretty normal to do everything via
apps.
For example,
when you visit China,
you rarely pay with credit cards.
The most common thing is to pay with a
mobile phone using the APP we chat.
This is something of a super app that is
like an all in one facebook page,
twitter,
etc.
By the way,
we chat is also owned by ten cent,
one of the top 15 most valuable
companies in the world,
which is also the world's largest
supplier of online games and one of the
largest shareholders of tests
by now.
You proBably realizing that,
oh yes,
the chinese,
they are everywhere.
as for another example of their success,
do consider ali baba or an ecommerce
company that brings in $450,000,000,000
every year and in China relaying this
company,
it has $400,
million clients and dwelled,
as napoleon said,
let's try and asleep for when she wakes
up,
she will shake the wells,
but before we all getting at sketch,
just have a think about what it means.
It means more competition.
It means better prices,
better products,
and faster technological developments.
As consumers,
we can benefit a great deal from this
transition.
Now obviously it does have plenty of
risks to,
or at least this is what us intelligence
agencies all warning,
according to the house,
permanent select committee on
intelligence is report.
Chinese companies cannot be trusted to
be free of foreign state influence and
thus posted security threat to the
United States and to our system,
and then there's the risk are companies
which are going to have more and more
competition all day.
They're also going to have more and more
opportunities to which we previously
discussed in the video.
That will link to you on the screen now,
but let's not get too ahead of
ourselves.
Chinese companies all still far behind
in technological terms as they are in
debt and well a great deal of it.
Chinese corporate debt levels are too
high,
but it will take time to bring them down
to more manageable level.
This,
this is not the end of this.
Don't forget that China is a
dictatorship and this means that the
government tends to much power when it
comes to corporate decisions.
Further,
the government's is pretty arbitrary and
it's really unpredictable.
For example,
a few years ago,
the government encouraged chinese
companies do try the international
markets and they would loan them as much
money as they needed to do so.
Now they've decided they want to do the
opposite.
If a chinese company that wants to buy
out a foreign company,
the need the approval of the chinese
communist party and there are new tough
limitations on money leaving the country
further to that,
we have to mention the censorship,
the legal uncertainty,
trade obstacles and the bad reputation
of chinese products and so on and so
forth.
So we can say that right now,
the United States,
his position as leader is not in
particular danger unless something
changes that is more dramatic than we
are currently seeing.
Long term though.
Well,
who knows?
So I really hope you enjoyed that video.
Please do hit that like button if you
did and do not forget to subscribe if
you haven't already brand new videos
every monday and every thursday and
don't forget to check out the reconsider
media podcasts.
They provided the vocals in this video
that are not mine.
And as always,
I'll see you in the next one.